blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman i want to start today with
something that many of us at this point
intuitively probably understand and
something that's also been made explicit
by the fbi and other law enforcement
agencies over the last year or two
which is that at this point in time for
the united states without saying
anything about times past necessarily
right now
the u.s is facing uh as
way more domestic terror threats as
foreign terror threats there's a very
interesting
newsweek article about this which says
the us is facing far more domestic
terror threats than those from
international parties according to the
fbi
timothy langan assistant director of the
bureau's counterterrorism division told
lawmakers wednesday that the u.s is
approaching more than 2700
domestic terrorism threats the number of
international terror threats is under
one
langan also gave statistics on
terrorism-related deaths in the u.s from
2015 to 2020. there were 80 reported
international terrorism-related deaths
compared with 83 deaths linked to
domestic terrorism
um langan's testimony follows fbi
director christopher wray's statements
to congress earlier this month when he
said the number of domestic terrorism
cases has exploded in the last year and
a half a recent ap poll found more
americans are concerned about threats
from extremist groups based on based in
the u.s as opposed to those from other
countries
65 percent of u.s adults report being
extremely or very concerned about
domestic group threats compared with 50
feeling the same about foreign extremist
groups
um
we there there's a couple things here
one is it's really common
that
people's fear of things is often out of
line with the actual
danger of that thing
uh we see this with vaccine stuff right
there are lots of people who are afraid
of kovid but this movement of people
afraid of the vaccine when really it's
coveted you should be much more afraid
of that would be one example in general
people tend to worry much more about for
example being the victims of a terrorist
attack despite it being insanely
unlikely that any of us would ever be
doesn't mean some people won't be but
statistically speaking insanely unlikely
versus things we don't think much about
like getting in a car every day which is
actually um a comparatively dangerous
thing given the number of people who die
yearly from terrorism in the u.s versus
the number who die in car accidents or
being more afraid of flying than driving
in a car even though the driving in the
in a car
is far more dangerous okay so so that's
one thing that oftentimes even though
the domestic terror threat is a bigger
threat people think of the idea of often
it's
dangerous muslims from the middle east
or sometimes it would be brown
immigrants from latin america or
whatever the trope of the week month or
year happens to be
um but then number two
you know there are entire media
apparatuses in the united states that
are very similar to what we see in other
countries
radicalized people
into what is often referred to in the us
as a
jihadist terror or islamic
or islamist terror
we have the equivalent in the united
states of these media outlets that
spread hate uh and so fear and
radicalize people
and many americans don't recognize them
as being the sort of domestic
equivalents of the stuff that we say wow
how do these people these people end up
getting radicalized into isis for
example and you look at the media and
the internet content but then we wonder
how did so many people end up getting
radicalized to the point where they
rioted on january 6th or
they put pipe bombs in washington dc or
whatever the case may be
and then you look at what we have
happening on facebook and oan newsmax to
some degree uh fox news and uh uh alex
jones and so many others this stuff
radicalizes people as well
and um
[Music]
it should come as no surprise that when
the rubber hits the road the domestic
terror
is actually far more of a threat
mathematically
than the foreign terror and yet another
report from the fbi confirms exactly
that now if you think that
although the number
may be greater
it makes sense because well you're in
the u.s so the americans are already
here that doesn't mean that
they're more dangerous on average there
may be more of them and you know if it's
83 versus 80 deaths from terror the fact
that there are more threats doesn't mean
that much i would disagree the fact that
there are that many potential nodes of
radicalism and terrorism domestically uh
means that there's way more people who
could be activated could be activated by
the exact type of rhetoric that we've
been fighting against let me know your
thoughts
this is something a little different
i don't think anybody has covered this
okay because one of our viewers tanner
wrote to me and said hey david big fan
of the show
after seeing many of the ridiculous
responses to mask mandates across the
country i decided to see if this is
happening at my local school board i
watched the most recent meeting and was
not disappointed i have attached a video
in which a middle school student and her
dad both quote hitler during their
anti-mask presentations to the school
board this is really wacky stuff okay
i'm gonna play this for you this is the
thompson school district
they claim to be the 17th largest school
district in colorado
they claim to have about 15 000 students
under their purview you really have to
see this this is daughter and then dad
who quote hitler in their opposition to
masking and the crowd cheers it's crazy
this is charlotte and thomas we're
starting with charlotte here
uh
this is very depressing let's take a
look
and by the way i apologize about the
audio quality it's it's very harsh
hi my name is charlotte k i am from
birthing i like to start my address with
a quote from a famous politician
he alone who owns the youth gains the
future okay the famous politician she's
referring to is adolf hitler
just so people know quoting hitler
i was a student at turner middle school
i say was because i had to leave your
school district because of how your
teachers were treating
the second week i was there you made a
mask mandate i did not wear a mask
because i have medical conditions that
make it so i can't wear masks
and because of that i was segregated and
sent to the library
when i attempted to use my rights to
speak freely i read the 14th and 15th
amendment my constitution was ripped out
of my hand and when i tried to
video what the staff were doing the
teacher took my phone i mean is this so
the sad thing here is right all of this
language about my rights were taken away
i was trying to cite amendments from the
constitution
a kid doesn't come up with this stuff by
themselves and you'll see when the dad
comes up exactly where it's coming from
is this a form of child abuse i mean you
know 14th amendment
uh granting all persons born and
naturalized in the u.s a guarantee of
equal protection 15th amendment the
right of citizens to vote shall not be
denied or abridged on the basis of race
color or previous condition of servitude
what masks guys come on and she
continues then just to make my day even
better the teacher said i was a terrible
person and i was a horrible child
then she told me i was going to kill
everyone in school and to quote the same
politician again
if you tell a big enough fly until
freaking enough you it will be believed
the same politician that's adolf hitler
again that's the she's quoting hitler
you say that you're supposed to keep a
student safe and cactus from the big bad
bullies
but you and your teachers are bullying
me
and
all those other students in the district
how does that work
all of your students left speak a lot of
your students left because of those
actions when i tried to show myself my
504 form
the teachers took it and ripped it to
pieces destroying my property
when i was in school i had to go home
multiple days because i had massive
headaches due to the masks
the classroom was and the classroom
being above 90 degrees when i used to
love school but now i don't you have
room in school for me and fortunately
it's too late it's too late for me
but i will fight for all the other kids
in your school district including my
older sister
i hope you're happy now that you ruined
my love for school
and one last time to quote uh the famous
politician adolf hitler when diplomacy
ends
war begins thank you for all your
consideration
[Applause]
so quoting hitler three times there now
i i have i'm not making fun of this girl
i see her as a victim
i see her as a victim
probably of this guy
the dad okay here comes the dad we're
gonna pick up his comments uh in
progress as i guess we might say when
they do teaching we have a problem
we have a problem when we have board
members family and friends calling in to
further their agenda
that problem starts here
that problem starts with this board
a board who refuses to believe the
children when they are mistreated a
board who sold our children into mass
mandates for 18 million dollars how much
will it cost to sell our children into
mandatory vaccines
what else are you willing to sell our
children into
how many children have to be mistreated
abused or assaulted before the board is
willing to look into an incident
your mission statement is mindless
drivel
it is here a lip service to this
community that makes you feel good about
what you do
i have lost face in this board and based
on your staff and your actions you do
not have our children i assume he means
he lost faith in the board not lost face
losing face is something different
children's best interests at heart
with that said i call for the immediate
resignation of everyone on this board a
lot of resignation people just
everybody's calling for resignations
these days we have no confidence in you
we have no trust in you and you have not
shown one ounce of diplomacy and like my
daughter said when there is no diplomacy
there is war
and even staring down the members of the
school board there uh so so like father
like daughter
both quoting hitler in their anti-mask
screeds um again
i see
the daughter as a victim
uh and i see uh this all really i mean
we we we can't attack this kid this kid
got the idea of being like this from
somewhere and you see exactly where it
came from this is really sad stuff
and unfortunately
these types of presentations are likely
not going away anytime soon let me know
your thoughts find me on twitter at
dpacman you can submit
submit videos of your local school board
meeting if you want to info
davidpakman.com we'll cover them
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things
you can have conversations with people
about more topics blinkist makes you
more well-rounded try blinkist for free
and get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show is
disproportionately funded by folks like
you who sign up on our website get a
membership and uh
i guess just revel in all of the great
membership perks that are available you
can sign up at
joinpackman.com
and you can use the coupon code better21
to get a big discount
let's talk to people in the audience why
not we do calls now via discord you can
find us at davidpakman.com
discord
join the discord almost 15 000 now on
the discord
and uh we can we can chat let's do it
let's start today
um with
oh how about uh i don't know
it's so tough to say how about ronnie
from new york you are first on today
hey david can you hear me okay yes i can
hey i was just curious are we ever gonna
see producer lewis again on the show
as an employee or just like as a guest
appearance
uh maybe just as a guest oh yeah yeah
he's welcome any time to my streams i've
even invited him on a couple times but
he's been you know very tied up with
either mowing his lawn or video gaming
or different things so it's hard to find
just that perfect time for louis to
appear but i actually i had lunch with
him yesterday and he's doing well
he's soon going to be shifting over to
an electric vehicle going fully electric
and uh yeah he's no no no other news
really with lewis but he's welcome
anytime
okay well that's all i had to ask thank
you all right thanks ronnie there's a
there's ronnie from new york with a very
strong question
um let's go next to sd from dallas texas
sd you're on the air
hi david
what is your take on so
uh the states are now making
the uh new maps for all the
legislative districts and i want to know
what's your take so far on
the gerrymandering for uh this coming
decade
i've not read that much about it other
than there are some interesting
districts that could just be eliminated
like for example lauren bobert's
district i guess if the proposed map is
accepted she may just not have a
district anymore
um i i've not
you know one of the things i'm trying to
do is when there's like maybes
let's wait and see if something is
happening unless there's really
something specific that could be done to
change the course and with with a lot of
this the gerrymandering and district
drawing that's being proposed
we're still waiting to see like what are
the final submissions and are they even
really going to be accepted so i don't
know i mean
what's your take is it are there
particularly egregious examples that we
should be looking at
oh yes oh yes yeah you can look at
states like um
like texas and
ohio it is like absolutely egregious uh
the uh the state legislature here
absolutely murdered
the uh the dfw area um but i guess what
i was really more looking into is um
knowing that the gerrymandering is going
to be pretty egregious across a lot of
these red states
uh is it worth dropping the principle of
no gerrymandering in blue states and
just fighting fire with fire at this
point i know this is always the thing
which is if the republicans are just
going to keep doing it in the states
they control isn't it uh unilateral
disarmament to say all right well we'll
draw them fairly in the blue states
and then they'll draw them completely
unfairly uh in in the red states i think
on this
for as long as these are the rules
democrats have no choice but to use the
system to their advantage when they can
because otherwise we will never even get
the opportunity to change how this is
done but
um
the goal has to be to change the system
and then of course you get to this
question of are people who
got in because of the system we have
really going to be motivated to change
it and that's a very legitimate question
which we addressed i think it was last
week on the show but no i mean listen if
if democrats just say
let's draw perfectly square districts
everywhere and do everything perfectly
and then republicans keep doing like
their dan crenshaw districts it's one of
the most egregious examples of
republicans do
then it just further makes it so that
democrats will never actually be in
power and able to really deal with this
issue so it's unfortunate but it is what
it is
right on david thank you very much my
pleasure thank you so much for the call
very important question very important
question there are areas where we say
we're not going to stoop to that level
because then we are as bad as them
when this is the system
you know it's sort of like saying i
won't even accept political donations
okay well then we just lose right okay
we have to work to change we have to do
campaign finance reform but we will
never even get that opportunity if
everybody on the left is like i won't
even do campaign donations no the person
who raises more money tends to win and
it's just an unfortunate reality
let's go next to
oh let's go to brody from dallas we
haven't heard from brody for a while
what's going on there
hey what's up david i'm doing pretty
well um how are you i'm doing well thank
you
thanks i wasn't expecting you to call me
so quickly uh
it's good to speak to you again i
had a few questions regarding the
infrastructure bill and the midterms
um as you probably and as you reported
on and are aware the progressive caucus
are seeking uh to basically get the deal
that was agreed to previously which is
the infrastructure and the
um
you know both deals moving at the same
time do you anticipate um
if it fails you know meaning if both
bills are not passed at the same time
that the blame is going to be placed on
the progressives solely do you think it
will be blamed on the democrats what do
you think the fallout will be and what
do you anticipate to happen with that
bill it really depends on the media
coverage between now and whenever that
ultimately happens i think that
all of the usual suspects are going to
do all of the usual blaming so
republicans will blame democrats for
crazy bills too much spending blah blah
blah
centrist democrats will try to blame the
progressive wing the progressive wing
will say
centrist democrats trying to make nice
with republicans is what ultimately so
ev all the usual suspects will do all
the normal blaming
what narrative succeeds
is ultimately going to depend on
corporate media coverage and and that
that is unfortunately always the case
but i just think there's no way to know
right now everybody will attempt to
blame exactly who we would expect but
whether that will stick in the minds of
people as this is who is to blame i just
don't know yet it's sort of like when we
have this debt ceiling issue
and
sometimes the public
blames democrats more sometimes they
blame republicans more typically it's
just the fault of republicans um but the
media coverage of it is often what
determines who gets the blame
politically it's an unfortunate reality
but it is the reality
and then one last quick question do you
think that there'll be any fallout from
the death ceiling argument and posturing
with regards to
maybe increasing support for changing or
carving out the filibuster or do you
think it'll remain the same i'm not i'm
not sure i know what you mean whether
whether the filibuster argument will be
affected by whether these bills pass i'm
sorry
on a separate track with mcconnell
posturing over the debt ceiling and
shutting down the government will that
put any impetus in a change on uh how
folks feel about the filibuster sadly i
don't think so unfortunate i i don't i
don't know i guess to just keep it short
i don't think so
well thanks david it's good to talk to
you pleasure all right there is uh
there's brody from dallas
uh let's go next to ricky from charlotte
is that is that charlotte north carolina
i presume
yes it is david can you hear me i can
hear you fine
okay awesome thanks for taking my call
uh so i wanted to ask you
i've kind of noticed it seems to me like
the right
is better at
stigmatizing and demonizing
words
and certain things are associated with
the left
more than the left is so just to give
like an example
um
you know
for
decades they've worked on demonizing the
term socialism
and it's kind of stuck and all the like
you know left-wing sort of economic
schools of thought like you would you
know if you're just a normal person if
you would think that you know marxism is
synonymous with genocide or something
like that but i just don't see the the
left like as doing as good of a job as
like you know demonizing a lot of ideas
that are associated with the white right
the only example i can think of is like
we've kind of demonized nationalism but
i kind of see that they they're trying
to revive that what do you think i
completely agree with you and you're not
the only person to notice this uh george
lakoff has written about this
to some extent thomas frank has written
about this um that this is you know you
go back to the very basic framing of for
example
tax relief
tax relief is is evil genius in a sense
right
you relieve people of taxes taxes are a
burden it's just taxes burden people you
get rid of taxes you relieve the burden
that is a completely absurd and myopic
framing of the fact that
government needs to be able to do things
and we have decided that we don't do
uh in most places a private fire
department or police department and and
roads and all these different things uh
but the term tax relief at a structural
level
um pushes things in favor of the right
and the left has to argue against that
and it they've done it with socialism
they've done it with abortion you know
pro-life
um i think that there are definitely
opportunities for the left to take to
win the branding game you know one
example that
this should have started a year and a
half ago
uh these republicans who are crazy about
the pandemic either they don't want to
deal with it in a serious way whatever
they should start to be called pro virus
right they're on the side of the corona
virus that's the way that it should be
framed and it's if i if i'm the only one
doing it it's not going to do anything
but if that had been the framing for a
long time
um that when they do these things they
are really on the side of the virus we
may have been able to change the
trajectory even a little bit of the way
that the pandemic was dealt with i think
there are opportunities but you're
completely right that for the most part
the left is not doing well on this issue
of naming and framing
whoops i accidentally i'm sorry i
accidentally muted you there what were
you saying
oh sorry can you hear me now yes i can
no it was my fault i apologize
no problem the i was just going to say
the one more recent thing that i've
noticed and it's kind of made me mad
that ever since the like social justice
protest last year a bunch of these
boomer republicans for the first time
you know heard the term woke and they've
done everything to demonize it like
saying that i i like i really hate
what's happened to the term because i
think back you know it's it's not a new
thing it's been around for a while and
it was always just about like you know
be conscious of uh it was about being
conscious no like history like
understand like
uh how the systems work and everything
and don't just always fall for the
mainstream narrative now you know
they've effectively demonized it to
where it just means like anything you
know that's
uh
like you know they'll call any sort of
climate change proposal woke or anything
like this and i feel like it's effective
and it's just
i i like i hate how we're losing that
battle it's the exact same thing that
happened with regressive left where
there was a very brief period where
regressive left
really meant
something or someone or an idea
that is ostensibly left
but it is actually an authoritarian
regressive thing and for a very short
period of time it actually worked to
define and point to something it then
just became bastardized by the right and
anything left they just call regressive
that's it so so yeah they they're
they're winning on all fronts on that
unfortunately
yeah well hopefully we can win it but i
appreciate you taking my call david you
have a great day thank you thank you for
calling in great uh very important issue
no question about that
um let's go next to
donnie from is it pronounced
visalia visalia how do you pronounce it
um visalia visalia okay good where where
is that yes
it's a central california county about a
45 minutes south of fresno oh beautiful
area
yeah yeah um so yeah i've been trying to
get a hold of you and let you know about
uh
i suspect i'm pretty sure
that because q is the 17th letter of the
alphabet
uh and
i know i heard stuff about
trump using 17 flags or something like
that but
i believe that's why he was always
saying
uh
the 1917 pandemic was to kind of send a
shout out to q supporters oh that is
fascinating let me see if i understand
this one so
q is the 17th letter of the alphabet is
that true i'm taking your word for that
i mean i haven't personally looked it up
but it was on documentaries that i had
seen the cnn is the third m is the 13th
so m-n-o-p-q would make it the 17th
right okay q is the 17th letter of the
alphabet
i guess did trump regularly have 17
american flags on the stage or was that
like once
i had heard that well i don't know it
might have been only once i have heard
that he had did that once but i believe
that's why he kept referring to the 1918
pandemic as a 1917 pandemic that's
fascinating
send a shout out to two supporters it's
probably not the case he's probably just
an idiot and he once said 1917 and then
he kept saying it because he can't admit
but that's fascinating that that's uh
that that's a signal to cue the q people
that's funny
yeah
you're kind of going in and out there
donna
all right
oh boy all right i'm gonna let you go a
very very funny uh instinct and and
suggestion
the connection left a little bit of
something to be desired there
let's go next to harper from marseille
france harper you're on the air
hello oh boy
harper your connections atrocious oh and
harper harper already left harper
self-selected out either panicked or
realized or got disconnected
uh let's try another international call
let's go to syed from bangladesh syed
you're on the air oh
hello uh thank you for you know actually
uh selecting me i have been you know
like trying to get on your call for a
few i'd say weeks i guess
my pleasure
so okay
uh
the the thing i'm going to ask you it's
not really you know like it's sort of
you know your opinion i would really
like to you know like uh you know know
what you feel about this so hear me out
so as you can you know like uh
completely guess i am not from america
right but i can you know like in a lot
of you know like because of a lot of
international you know issues and stuff
we end up you know like listening to our
you know american politics and you know
like basically international
involvements and basically so
during this you know like pandemic and
you know the other stuff when i had you
know much more you know like time to
actually you know look through all of
the stuff i have noticed something you
know like very
it's a surprising in you know let's say
in america right now
so hear me out on this one uh currently
i can see that you know most of the
people who are you know let's say
they're right-wingers you know they're
religious or whatnot
and they are basically you know like
trying to you know like uh
they have their own set of ideologies
let's say and left have their own set of
ideologies and right now
let's see the muslim populations in the
west they are kind of you know like
in a scenario where they sort of feel
like they are in some kind of you know
political homelessness that is something
that i'm going to say
so let's say you know like uh
someone is you know like a practicing
you know muslim let's say and you know
he wants to you know
basically follow you know like
traditional stuff and do religious or
worshiping and other stuff like that and
you know
basically a person like that you know
oftentimes you know like doesn't get
along with you know let's say you know
insane
someone who is you know like a very
hardcore lefty right and then you have
you know on the other side the right
wingers who are actually you know like
they claim to be religious and you know
they are you know practitioners of
mostly christianity and then they have
problems with you know muslims right so
i have seen this you know scenario where
like muslims feeling like political
homelessness and like any kind of
i'd say you know like uh the right wing
people i would say that you know
they're basically shooting themselves in
their foot you know when they are you
know doing all this you know like let's
say some sort of anti-muslim stuff yeah
and you know and then they're wondering
yeah why are we losing
right
i think it's a very astute point so if
you consider the religious muslim
community
you have folks who
culturally
are really more in line with the
religious christian community often in
terms of
the role they want to see religion play
in civil government in terms of cultural
norms in terms of social norms but
republicans in the united states they
are like that only with regard to
christianity and sometimes they'll
pretend with judaism as well although
really they're often anti-semitic but
there's there's more confidence i know i
know
so
that's really where the muslims would
would find a cultural social home but
the republicans don't want them and then
on the left
those very same religious muslims would
often say oh these folks want secularism
that's not what i want either and it
leaves these folks sort of out out in a
no man's land i think it's a very astute
analysis and i think you're completely
right syed
i think
it is going to like ah let me explain a
scenario like i'm gonna uh
we'll say it i have so many people
holding i'm gonna let you go now because
we we've done i think we've done a good
amount today but call back okay but i
love the point you made
okay okay very good all right syed from
bangladesh extraordinarily good point
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because i'm going
right back to the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount join
pacman.com
all right let's hear from a few more
people we do calls via discord you can
find the david pakman show discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's uh in this next uh tranche of
calls
let's go to
um alexander the texan alexander you
were on the air
hi david i hope you're doing well thank
you
um
so i just wanted to get your take on
something
so i'm seeing with a lot of what i would
call the american bad leftists and a lot
of the general right wing
two specific stories that they ran
really hard on one of which being
uh allegations of perjury against
anthony fauci that the intercept wrote
about yep the other of which being
excuse me
the
current
stories about hunter biden
among more of the uh common sense left
wing channels
i would go as far as the saying it seems
like like this story is being kind of
ignored i would just like to hear your
thoughts on this please sir yeah so i'll
go backwards i mean with the hunter
biden stuff
i just don't really get
what the story would be
for me so when i see the head you know i
follow the right wing headlines and i
see that i think it was last week maybe
five days ago a bunch of articles popped
up about hunter biden's emails again and
pictures or whatever i just don't get
what the story is for me i mean he's a
guy who has struggled in his life he's
not only not the president but unlike
with trump because biden doesn't you
know have his his kids working for him
hunter's not involved in government so i
just don't really know what the story is
other than
just that his last name is biden and
he's joe biden's son so that's why i've
i've not covered that one does does that
make sense i think people are
complaining about the
nepotism of the fact that he was able to
get
certain jobs or certain things through
his dad being the vice president and it
would seem in the emails that have been
released
that
that's kind of being corroborated now of
course i'm i'm a simpleton from texas so
i try to just get smarter people that
uh talk about these things for me to
understand but i i'm having a hard time
seeing both
sides connect on this it seems that one
is saying look he's a drug addict
nothing more the story and the other
side is saying hey that's not even the
story
the story is actually all of these other
things that he was able to do because
his dad was vice president yeah i mean i
think what makes this tough is there's
an attempt being made to say that
it's just like ivanka don jr eric and
kushner in terms of getting stuff
because his dad was vice president
it it seems to me not even remotely
equivalent i mean trump had his kids
working for him
uh ivanka was sitting in for trump uh
once when they were in was it uh japan
or
i don't even know helsinki i don't
remember when or sat in for the
secretary of state like
i think that to some degree
if you're the vice president's kid
there are going to be opportunities for
you to do things that will be given to
you and then there's a question as to
whether you do something inappropriate
or not and we can sort of explore that
it just seems to be on a different
playing field than what trump was doing
with his kids and the very people
obsessed with hunter
said nothing and don't even care about
what was going on with kushner and
ivanka and don junior so it seems a
little bit hypocritical to me i would
say
i i i can agree with that sentiment uh
what about the the issues around faculty
and the allegations of perjury yeah i
looked at that and just it didn't seem
to me that the credib that there was
credibility to the perjury allegation i
have you know that we weren't funding
gain of function research you think that
that wasn't semantics that that's
literally the case that that there was
no american funding in any
in any stretch of gain of function
research do you believe that that's the
case you know um how can i answer this
in in the most sort of like a relevant
way
uh i i agree with you that there's there
is a semantic component to this
in terms of how does an institution
define gain of function research
and how are republicans defining it in
this war they're waging against anthony
fauci so to some sense in some sense it
actually the semantics are sort of like
what's relevant here let me put it a
different way
i have seen
no evidence to date that anthony fauci
was for malicious reasons
hiding the nature of what the u.s was
funding regardless of the name you
assigned to it and i'm willing to have
my mind changed about that if someone
can show me no
fauci was deliberately obfuscating he
knows he was obfuscating and the spirit
of what he was saying it not
semantically but the spirit of what he
was saying was wrong i've not seen
evidence of that today
okay this very eloquently said and i and
i very much appreciate your point of
view and uh thank you for taking my call
my pleasure alexander the texan i might
even call it a perfect phone call quite
frankly um
very glad to exchange ideas on that
front
let's go next to uh
let's go to greg peach
greg peach from where where are you
calling in from greg
hello
oh uh i'm calling from georgia
okay very good you're on the air greg
and there's music in the background
there's wind chimes there's many
different things happening
i just want you to have a pleasant
experience on this call with me david
thank you no it's the wind chimes are
relaxing go ahead
um
okay
uh so yeah i have
um
i guess um
shoot i had a
um oh i have i have a question for you
so
do you still believe that there's a
population of people that will hear
that joe biden uh doesn't want them to
get vaccinated and will go and get
vaccinated out of spite
you're saying if if they came to believe
that joe biden like didn't want
republicans vaccinated they would be
like i'll show him i'm gonna go and get
vaccinated you're asking if i think
those people exist
uh yeah and you've mentioned this before
on your your show so if i didn't
i'm basically
asking if what you mentioned before on
your show is still
i believe you have yeah i think so i
think if it and it's not it's more it's
a little more complicated than if joe
biden said it if there was a narrative
that joe biden was gonna take away the
vaccine from right wingers after a
certain date like i know it's crazy
right it would never happen but if a
large portion of the right came to
believe that i think many of them would
rush out to get vaccinated just despite
joe biden for sure
okay so my follow-up to that is
as somebody with a
widely seen news show do you have a
moral imperative to make fake news to
spread that narrative to save lives it's
a beautiful question i i think that uh
it would be wrong for me to unilaterally
start spreading that and i can't
actually articulate why but one of the
things that i try to do on this show
is never
to lie to my audience about my beliefs
and so
it fundamentally would go against
my approach
to say something on the air that i don't
believe to be true
specifically to trick people into doing
something and you're you're right that i
might be doing it with the intention of
saving lives by getting people
vaccinated but
it's one of those principles that i just
can't really get over the hump and say
i'm gonna lie i'm gonna say things on
the show i know to be a lie
okay great that's my question thank you
all right greg p now if people disagree
with me if people think no i in that
situation i should be making an
exception i should be lying to my
audience because of the
uh objective
it's a means to an end let me know i
think that that would be uh
certainly interesting for sure
let's go to john from uh is it lester or
leicester
it's lester you gotta write the first
time
i suspected
nice listening to the audience being i
see it but i guess
how are you doing because i guess i
don't know i watch the american news
vicariously through you and some other
sources as well not to balance it just
because i like the way they talk and i
don't know
it's messed up huh i mean i'm sorry
you're cutting out a little bit are you
saying did you say are things messed up
here
yeah like i guess like more interested
about how you're doing with it all
because it seems like i don't know
i guess from my perspective of dealing
with the crap that's going on in britain
yeah it's quite distressing like you
know oh i see what you're saying i don't
know yeah listen i mean i've talked
about uh maintaining a healthier media
diet and balance and so like basically
for three full days a week i'm tuning
out of the news all together and i'm
just you know i'm doing my biking i'm
doing my running i'm reading uh you know
doing other stuff um i i think it it
particularly when there is so much
craziness going on really important to
get a break and that's i i would
consider it a mental health break from
the substance that i normally consume
for my job that's my approach
oh nice that's good that's fit that's
all my question was man you know it's
good to get taken care of though thank
you and things are okay in leicester
i mean i don't know i've been locked
down for like a year in a bit it's not
too bad yeah you stress
what is it what does it mean that you're
in lockdown do you go to the grocery
store
uh well now we do but like i'd say for
the first like let's start covid no like
it was basically like you go to the shop
and then you come back and then you just
live at home
okay i got to go outside actually that's
not fair to say i work in the nhs so i
had to go outside but literally my for
about a year and maybe a bit
we've been living indoors which is fun
and are you uh are you going to
restaurants or pubs and sitting outside
for example
first i went to a pub was uh last
weekend
okay so you're no longer in lockdown i
guess is what you're saying
no but it's like a semi lockdown it's
weird like for example at work i still
have to wear a mask if i visit people at
home i wear a mask but if i go outside
of the shops i don't wear a mask it's my
choice but i still wear a mask got it
got it all right very good john i
appreciate the call
noiseman you take care all right there
we go beautiful uh pleasant phone call
from lester it looks like it would be
lyster but it's not
i learned that many years ago a lot of
people won't tell you that but i will on
this program uh i appreciate everybody
who called in i'm sorry i wasn't able to
get to every call
but we will take calls again my friends
thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright let's get into
the mail bag with a couple bonus
comments and facebook messages this week
uh we tried this segment sort of on a
whim a few weeks ago
and um
people are loving it and the number of
emails coming in uh has gone up
dramatically more people have a lot of
things to say
um but the reaction also people are
really getting interested by the things
that that people are writing so let's
just go right to it remember you can
send me an email info davidpakman.com
please don't send 20 emails if you do
they're going to get auto deleted so
just be reasonable okay guys if you're
sending me 20 emails
in a day or two um we're probably not
getting them because you've probably
been blocked my friends okay first
message is from tom
about the veyers system that's the
vaccine reporting system tom says hi
david i recently looked into the vayer's
website and was stunned to find that
individuals are allowed to very easily
report whatever they want at any given
time i downloaded the gab app to keep up
on mega trends and they all seem to be
very aware of the acronym there's but it
appears as though only the influencers
on the right know how unreliable the
data actually is
they have begun and probably have in the
past used it to make wild claims it's
disgusting and disheartening i look
forward to hearing your take thank you
tom yeah i've said this before
um you can report anything you want to
the vare system
and then that data is used by
right-wingers to say look at all these
reports with never mentioning you can
report anything now last time i
mentioned this someone wrote to me and
they said david sir
um
you know it's a crime to falsely report
okay that but that's fine are we hearing
about anybody getting in trouble for
false reports there's every indication
there are endless false reports
it should be mentioned
very very important
kevin from toronto wrote to me
and well this is about our story about
amazon now pushing for cannabis
legalization we said what's the what's
the game here kevin says hey david the
thing i thought of immediately just
hearing the headline that amazon is
pushing for cannabis legalization is
that amazon could make a lot of money
selling and distributing it cannabis is
lightweight very easy to ship and many
retailers and producers would surely use
an amazon store if it was allowed
especially the rapid shipping options
would be very desirable for cannabis
customers i agree 100
um i think you know amazon was very
clear about a lot of this has to do with
just
smoothing out the hiring uh by
eliminating cannabis as an obstacle
which maybe makes sense but at the same
time they could just say we don't care
about cannabis use regardless of its
legality there may be an e-commerce
opportunity there
um that amazon is is interested in many
people writing in with that exact same
point of view
helen wrote in and says just a thought
when you talk about governors and their
stance on vaccines
please mention whether they themselves
are vaccinated i think that when we know
that's a great idea i don't
i'm not sure if we know the vaccination
status of all 50 governors but if we do
a story about such governor just came
out against vaccine mandates i think
it's perfectly reasonable to add
and by the way this governor is
vaccinated
or this governor is unvaccinated if we
know it very good idea
um brent wrote in this is another one of
those where i start wondering am i just
terrible at communicating information to
my audience are people really
misunderstanding
last week we did a segment about the lie
that thousands of people are dying from
the vaccine that the vaccine is causing
death
brent wrote to me
saying david
vaccinated people are dying from covid
let's look at the email david you do a
disservice when you say there are no
deaths among vaccinated people granted
they are rare
i know two vaccinated persons who have
died there are reports from the us and
uk of fully vaccinated people dying
fully vaccinated people are dying with
variance beyond delta
the anti-vax people are crazy but you
sound just as delusional when you
suggest there are no vaccinated deaths
again
i never said that i said that there is
no evidence the vaccines are the cause
of death
uh of course we know of breakthrough
infections and although it's a very
small percentage of what we might call a
breakthrough death but please
try to react to what i'm actually saying
rather than what
maybe you hope i'm saying or whatever
the case may be
i never denied vaccinated people died
what i said is the idea that thousands
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people are dying from the
vaccine
is not backed up by any facts by any
evidence that we are actually seeing
andrew wrote in
andrew says just you wait oh i can't
tell if this is a joke i j this is not
someone that has written to us before i
can't tell if this is satire andrew
wrote just you wait sirs
you guys are having a great time mocking
donald trump but just you wait until he
unveils obama gate then you will be
laughing out of the other side of your
faces it's the biggest political scandal
in the history of the us perhaps the
biggest in all of history no really
you'll see andrew i think this is satire
the use of sirs
as well as no really you'll see and
extraneous exclamation points including
double exclamation points i think this
is a satirist
who is just kidding around and they're
not really telling us to wait for
obamacare
john from jefferson city missouri wrote
in and says good day sir just curious
about whether statistics have been
collected to determine the percentage of
democrat versus republican that have
died from covet 19. this is a fantastic
question why
i don't know no it's this is a fantastic
question because we've been saying for a
while
as blue states get more vaccinated and
red states lag behind as republicans
remain one of the most anti-vaccine
groups in the country
at some point you would imagine the
virus will kill
more republicans than democrats
i believe we are already at that point
in time earlier this week on the
two
tuesday show on the tuesday show we
looked at a chart that looked at per
capita deaths over the last few weeks
compared to 2020 voting and what we saw
was that the heaviest biden states
places like
vermont massachusetts etc
have the lowest per capita death rate
the biggest trump states mississippi
alabama etc have the highest per capita
death rate over the last month
um
this
leads me to believe we are already
seeing a skew covet is killing more
american republicans than american
democrats is it enough to make the
difference in elections
we don't know yet
um could it be make or break in any
particular race
it's too early to say and maybe not but
my guess would be
when we see kovid killing more people
per capita in alabama than massachusetts
or in mississippi than in vermont
i would guess
that the data would bear out
it's not just people in those states
dying it's
overwhelmingly and disproportionately
republicans in those states dying and if
you have more republicans in a certain
state you would imagine that it's
disproportionately republicans over
democrats as well uh but a very very
good question and it probably is
increasingly already a republican virus
here's a couple bonus here is john lemon
from youtube who says
so i blame you mr pacman for the deaths
of fifteen thousand americans that have
died from taking the vaccine here's an
example of a vaccine deather as we maybe
we would call them
you are a sick deranged person who is
making big money off of big pharma to
say what you say prove it
this has come up a dozen times
why would anyone pay me to talk about a
vaccine we're meaningless in the grand
scheme of things why would why would
even if there was the volition to do
that why would anyone give me money to
talk about i got vaccinated and it seems
to be a good thing to do
john lemon goes on to say i bet also the
deep state and china are paying you off
you were a disgrace to this country very
very sick individual
very sick individual not even worth
refuting them on the merits it's just
you know you guys know this stuff is
around that that is another virus that
is spreading
john smith wrote in
uh in response to our uh announcement of
1 billion youtube views john smith wrote
back 1 billion idiots
see the durham report yeah looks like
the democrats were the ones spreading
the trump-russia bs
hillary herself knew can't wait for more
indictments this is someone who still
thinks hillary's going to prison
this will be very big but
trump he was right with being spied on
russia hoax election fraud next
the syntax is tough here john smith goes
on
how about you
did you going did you doing any
reporting on trump and russia collusion
i bet trump's lawyers are at work
getting ready to start lability lawsuits
he was slandered investigated how many
times
schiff cuomo at cnn and cnn
to get this so wrong by the media
i hope he's compensated
that is really tough to get through
john finishing his email to me his love
letter
by saying one of these days you will
appreciate trump the president and what
he did in four years is remarkable don't
hold your breath john
and then lastly an extra special bonus
in this week's mailbag this one coming
in
very early this morning 5 20 am
via facebook
you are a worthless piece of sht
peace spelled like world peace
it's a hoe
like you
that are it's by the way the wrong it's
that are destroying
my country
take your effing arse back to your own
country
i'm an american citizen or re-educate
your
regurgitated garbage
this is
really really weaponized stuff
and the prototypical example of
you're not going to sit down
with this person i'm going to say this
guy almost everyone who sends stuff like
this is is male
you're not going to sit down with this
guy and have a rational conversation and
get him to say you know what right
you're i was wrong you were right i'm
glad that you explained things to me the
way they are it's just not happening and
so it gets us once again to the question
of how do you deprogram that how do you
do it i don't have the answer
but we've talked with a lot of people
who claim to have some ideas
they say the only answer is long term of
building relationships with these folks
uh i i don't have the uh i don't have
the stomach for it i think is the way i
would say and i know many of you have
folks like these in your family i'm
sorry to hear that we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpackman.com you'll get instant
access and you can email me info
davidpakman.com keep it nice keep it
nice give me something productive we'll
see you on the bonus show otherwise
monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman